[Music]
[Applause]
beautiful
hey Town East welcome to a live episode
of dumb people Town population U
population all of us Eva I love that
you're here thank you you've listened
the show you've now you know yeah you're
in the show yeah I'm in the show one of
my favorite things are you rocking our
merch yeah yeah hey check it out check
it out the merch 6 p.m is the 3am of day
drinking that's a fact
go home if you started at noon and it's
6 p.m go home if it's 6 p.m and you and
your drunk girlfriend decide to break
into a zoo
with the Tigers go home it's 6 p.m
you're gonna throw up in a potted plant
go go home I'm feeling attacked I'm
feeling attacked by this but I'm still
gonna wear it if you're 60 If it's 6 pm
and you're riding a mechanical bull
go home did I close out
you're talking to a parking meter man
yeah go ahead and close out go home
or come to my house so Eva I love that
you brought the Bell which is my
favorite thing ever so Eva has a bell
and I met her in at Burning Man I don't
know he went to birming yeah
he never brings it up the sweater brings
it up
my I I'm I'm volunteering his tribute by
the way I also brought your sweaters
your sweater looks like you have nine
magazines subscriptions
and three ashtrays and no one smokes
your sweater looks like it whippers the
words black people
no so uh so Eva had this Bell and and
when I met her at Burning Man which I
went to and I don't know if you guys
know oh I didn't know that that's so
cool magical Burning Man magical you
guys know that that happened we were at
she was at a karaoke tent and I was
singing karaoke and every time someone
did something good or cool she
ding the Bell right there so anytime
someone would do something cool she
dinged the Bell which I thought was like
what a great bit to do over and over
again and I just every time someone sang
a great song or did a good version I was
like this is amazing then I got up to
sing and I was really [__] up I got up
to saying uh I Can't Go For That
no can do and by Daryl Hall Daryl Hall
he's from Philly
himself so I get up to do that and all
of a sudden out of nowhere not asked by
me two Dutch people I believe or German
let's make them German let's make them
German yeah they also one of them was
wearing a cape one of them was wearing a
cape at tracks nobody asked for that
came up and when I saw a guy in a cape I
literally said I Can't Go For That
thank you so they came up and they
started to sing back up on my song
Uninvited [__] yeah so they've got the
microphone and I'm singing I can't go
for that and Eva's watching me as these
people are behind me and I just gave
them a look like what the [__] was my
look like this she saw my look and
ding my life wonderful so the Bell is
here tonight if anybody says anything
that is fantastic or great or anything
happens a high degree of difficulty
Eva's gonna ring that Bell so that's
where part of that right hell yeah can
we bring them out well do you want to
read them do we do her are we doing her
first are we gonna do them all together
let's do them all together okay Jay you
want to bring here's the deal we have
guests on this show it's not just me
Randy and Dan this is sketchfest yeah
high level of talent are they back there
they'll walk out they'll get they're
gonna hear us saying their names get
ready get ready for the guests on our
show I might have to literally walk off
this stage Jay has traded the
awkwardness for them not being ready for
the awkwardness of this moment
and I framed one Globe isn't that weird
it was a shadow box guys it was it made
sense Jason is terrified that they're
not there they are on the steps they're
there they're there yeah okay okay Jay
introduce uh all right our first guest
is a hilarious comedian when did we meet
her on which show ran which show were we
doing that she was hilarious on it was
at JFL right it was a jfo it was it was
Black Shark Tank oh God it was so funny
she's not black neither are we but it
was a great episode of Shark Tank yeah
give it up for one of our favorite
things for the Bell comedians Robbie
offense badly
yes yes yes that is the correct response
to cheer wildly
our next guest is uh I don't even have
to stand but I'm doing this out of
reverence you're probably out of frame
uh
he is seriously one of our uh dearest
friends in comedy we recently hung with
him in Nashville he had a show we had a
show that was a great night the best
part of the night was hanging with him
afterwards the best part of the night
was going to get shitty tacos and then
all of us hoping that Kyle would not
cross the street while traffic was
coming I was like ladies gentlemen he
survived that street and he's here
tonight
look at him look at this beautiful man
I love you buddy picture of virility and
health ding the Bell Kyle there you go
be good if there was a coffee table here
yeah I survive all them streets
[Music]
the word jewelry now that's right
remember when you did try and cross this
River like this is a dumb idea he's not
gonna make it there was one moment where
I was like Kyle do you still have the
gout I asked you that you did have the
go I had a few weeks ago
I think it's cool the other guy I think
it's weird that you make MC's list that
as one of your credits when you do
stand-up comedy you might know this guy
from gout if people don't think you
could walk and then you show up walking
people get excited yeah you're right
you're starting ahead yeah yeah you love
the surprise yeah it's still happening
yeah oh yeah and how doubt was not gout
was not got the aloe puranol in my dab
kit to prove it
yeah um if possible I would love it if
we could have our own logo thrown up
here behind us because we are going to
have some photos including one which is
the Florida man name game do you guys
want to play at the Florida band name
game
look at us look at our logo look at our
logo I know I like it off dude that's us
sitting and falling into it don't
surprise yeah uh we can throw up that
Florida name game pick there we go there
we go
Robbie Hoffman yeah I love Florida I
have your the way this works is uh
everybody well that's not it nope you go
right back to where you were we'll get
to that later on let's go back and go
right back there we go
don't worry about that oh geez come on
also my mic keeps going in and out and I
would love for it to be a bit that we do
but I would also like it to not happen
tell me what you'd like and if at any
point we need to stop it down to switch
this out everybody's cool with it most
of all me
it's like when Dan was a bouncer at a
bar go ahead that's such a dad move to
give your kid the good mic and you take
the shitty Mike well we'll switch back
because I'm a I'm gonna do most of the
talking here but yeah okay you need a
good one when we get to yourself
give me the ice cream cone that fell on
the floor I'll eat that
so would I yeah exactly I just realized
this is Florida I thought it was a gun
it's Florida it is it's both it's both
it's Florida
uh Robbie
everybody has a birthday your Florida
man is what Florida man did on your
birthday wait everybody has a what day a
birthday oh okay I thought you said a
perfect day I said hold up hold on okay
everybody has a birthday true for his
birthday I have your birthday as
December 2nd is that correct yeah same
day as Britney Spears
you guys are always getting mixed up
people are like they are
okay yeah yeah I am what it does it
serves
serves me very well are we just dinging
if we're just excited yeah yeah he's got
a semi now so let's uh
that was what they call a labial ding
um
I'm not sure the rules
neither am I there are no rules Canadian
just get in that's right Robbie would
you like to hear the headline for what
your Florida man did on your birthday my
foreman Florida man do you want us to
turn up the monitors
you're you know what you speak you know
when somebody speaks without moving
their mouth no we don't realize how much
we're actually mouth reading I think a
lot of people don't realize so when
someone doesn't move their mouth you're
losing a lot also you should turn up
your Miracle Ear uh okay yeah exactly
okay so my Florida man is Florida man a
thing or you made it up you're your own
Florida man right now that's what's
happening what can I ask you your
dialogue is from Clearwater
change for you what is a Florida man
what would it change for you if it was a
thing or if I made it up
well because then you could explain it
if it's just a man from Florida I'm like
is it my uncle who is it my lips weren't
moving enough
okay okay go through the question this
is easily the most confrontational this
show has ever been
it's moments like this where you
understand that Robbie has nine brothers
I don't I don't feel safe being between
Dan and Robbie I can only get more fun
all right
uh I'm the only girl here so you don't
feel safe imagine the book what about
Eva Eva right behind you I can't confirm
all right
all right but I got you ring the bell I
don't know how she identifies okay God
Florida men great
tend to do crazy [__] good some would
say they do it every single day of the
year yeah all of us have a day in which
we are born yeah we are going to find
out what a probably man
did in Florida on your birthday fine
there we go we don't have to we don't
need to we don't have to I just watched
a guy pull a bike grip off a handlebar
with his teeth in the Mission District
yeah so maybe we need to take it easy in
Florida once in a while
he didn't get caught
happen on Robbie's birthday then it's
not
relevantage
I lived in Florida when I was a child
for a year oh where it was really you
know it wasn't great my father was
trying to live off my grandfather at the
time oh but the weather was terrific and
we stole some bikes so it was Panhandle
Panhandle how did you get the grips off
ripped them off do I get a picture of
the Florida man who did some [__] I just
get to hear the headlines all right Jay
give us a headline headline
Bobby Hoffman birthday December 2nd is
Florida man arrested for stuffing beef
tongue in pants at Walmart okay
to which I say Walmart is selling tongue
right now that's this is getting this is
veering anti-Semitic because Jews do eat
tongues
okay I've had a delicious tongue
sandwich once it's pricey so save up but
here's the form here's the story the
land police say 44 year old Jason
Puckett was charged last week with
misdemeanor theft after a Walmart
security guard spotted him slipping 35
dollars worth of beef tongue into his
waistband when the guard confronted
Puckett at the store's expert Puckett
denied stealing the packages and said he
put them back on the Shelf but the guard
told authorities Pucket then removed the
tongue from his pants the guard is such
a Narcan exactly if you're stealing
tongue believe me you need that time
let them have it let them have it okay
Walmart isn't stealing taking anything
from Walmart is is free for all which
piece of meat could you steal where they
would look the other way I would say
ears Hooves by the way if you said 35 of
tongue I would guess that's about eight
pounds of tongue all right that's a lot
of time it's a lot of tongue uh DJ Eva
I have your birthday is October 15th
would you like to know who your Florida
man birthday is desperately here it is
headline is this Florida man gets
settlement after officer thought donut
glaze was meth oh
a Florida man was arrested in 2015 after
police mistook donut glaze in his car
for meth he received a thirty seven
thousand dollar settlement
why was he keeping donut glaze in like
little plastic bags
on that
right Dan Rushing
pulled over 65 was arrested in December
2015 traffic stop but a cop saw flakes
of glaze on his car's floorboard and
thought they were pieces of crystal meth
oh my god do flakes of glaze would be
the best name for an indie rock band
train song
Santa Drops of Jupiter
how do they even see flakes of glaze
they're cops on it it was donut pieces
either way it should be a new donut that
they offer at the Village I agree I
agree also can you smoke those yes I'll
tell you this yeah I have a 14 year old
son we have not bought donuts for
decades I am convinced there might be
flakes of glaze in his bed right now I
oh okay
I agree and I should also mention my
in-laws are in the house okay okay
flakes the glaze flakes Kyle canane yeah
I have your birthday as December 23rd
you know it okay
here's your headline
and your Florida man here we go Florida
man arrested for handing out marijuana
quote because it was Christmas
the best
it could have been me
police in Pinellas County say Richard
Ellis Spurrier was Distributing to quote
several individuals the 67 year old man
also had a small amount of marijuana
hanging off his right shirt sleeve
if you're under it you do get to kiss
somebody related
that he was passing out the marijuana
quote because it was Christmas Spurrier
is facing a felony charge of possession
of marijuana with the intent to sell or
distribute here's my favorite part and
my favorite part of your Florida man
officers also found a hidden sword in
his Cane oh God
all right if you have a cane that
doesn't have a sword in it what the [__]
are you doing me I have out and also the
aforementioned
sword Kings
that's crazy yeah I love it
is it is is it me or is that guy handing
out the weed for Christmas earlier and
earlier every year
it's an earlier thing
I agree Florida Florida I mean is it
legal in Florida weed I don't know if
it's legal to distribute distribute it
at an elementary school I think that
it's it's a peninsula and the good ideas
only have one way out okay do you have
to be to arrest somebody for weed at
this point it's like there's other ways
to come out that's true that's true amen
so many all right it's okay to arrest
people for weed I think so at this point
it's like what are you a narc shut up
thank you to which a cop would go yes
yes
literally we
I'm a Narcotics officer I literally yeah
all right well uh let's go back to the
logo because we're gonna do Story number
one who has Story number one Jason I got
Story number one
how big are your feet dude I wear a size
14. God damn that's beautiful well I'm
actually a size eight but I wear a size
14. hello
Dan likes to have extra room I like the
room
uh all right you guys ready for the
headline for this first story yes couple
charged with engaging in sex act while
waiting in line at Cedar Point
wait what's Cedar Point Cedar Point is
an amusement park oh whoa I almost said
roller coaster these lines are too
[__]
look you know what else is long right
here [__]
which means it's long here right too all
right
what do you want me to nut on the
coaster yeah
I didn't realize
I'm depressurizing the cabin
rolling around we're gonna have a boy
that's what we're trying to do here I
didn't I didn't realize I was already on
Splash mode
[Music]
that is a really fast pass
um
swipe them through it had to be from
behind right this is I come on Daniel
well if he's really big he could just be
holding her when she's tired that's
right and a little bit of a you know
rocking her to sleep no yeah
I'm sorry hang on a second I'm sorry sir
are you trying to burp your wife yeah I
want him to be holding her like a koala
yes
we already both have herpes
if I don't do this she won't fall asleep
so creepy
she was tall enough to ride that ride
though I will say that um
the fact that he had her in a fact that
he had her in a Bjorn that also added an
element of weirdness to it
Whatever Gets you up all right uh
Sandusky Ohio I'm sorry that's already
an issue Sandusky police arrested two
adults like they had to say adults
because of Sandusky like they had to be
like they were both adults they're
adults on charges of public indecency
after officers say they were involved in
a sex act while waiting in line at Cedar
Point Friday evening look guys we know
the lines get long right what are you
gonna do in all that time it's always
worse when they say act like just say
sex because then when you say act then
we all get to like just imagine yeah
like because it could have been an HJ
yeah it could it could have been so many
other things like they were involved in
sex right I know what that is sex act we
don't know it could be anything
there could have been there could have
been there could have been mask work
wigs
object work will there be more
information
he could have taken his sword out of his
Cane so to speak or sheathed his sword
in his game I have an enlarged clitoris
I could vouch for that thank you once
again is that permanent or is it like a
just like when you sense Danger
it's actually when I'm most relaxed I
just think about those like lizards when
they're like sides go out all crazy
like we're in trouble that's bigger you
know I don't know I don't know what it
means I relate heavy to the micro dick
population oh geez same like when those
guys complain like oh we have a micro
think we gotta tell a girl and it's so
hard to have a micro dick I go I got no
dick you mean an enlarged clitori and
micro peni
share the same social space that's right
yeah
it's like people who are really
right-wing and really left-wing are just
like one issue apart yeah if this
conversation was going to happen
anywhere at San Francisco's because
there's at least nine bars that appeal
to that Community yes
and once again
in-laws are in the house uh you invited
them I know I told them we're all going
to ski balls after this yeah you wanted
to know what your son-in-law did this is
it uh all right here we go
according to police body camera video
and reports by the way that I'm trying
to picture that bar right now and I'm
assuming it would be a micro Brewery
where the doors are just huge
it's hard to open they always have
garage doors they always have garage no
it's just two giant velvet curtains uh
tiny little knobs yeah exactly okay
well the knob isn't large okay that's
right okay sorry okay it's bigger why is
the knob in Gorge okay uh an officer
told the couple that a witness took
video of the incident
of course a witness took video and this
is what the officer said quote we
clearly have video of you with your hand
down his pants an officer told the woman
that's just a friendly video that oh
yeah he's just getting a he joke on your
pants who first of all is sex illegal
it's in a public a public place no I'm
not down with that you could [__] in
line for cotton candy yes
every story I want you to be like what
is this person a [__] nerd what's
happening
why I can't [__] anymore no you can do
it I mean you can't what do you mean you
can't put her hair hand down her pants
in front of the teacups come on what is
this Russia maybe she needed a a uh uh
Ricola
digging around yeah cause that's the guy
he's like you can't even see your stroke
you can't even see her stroke let her be
look it is a Small World After All uh
brother thank you
uh that video by the way was sent around
to all group chats that that uh person
was on I need to say the couple of
course denied doing anything wrong yeah
okay this is the quote uh we just
started dating not too long ago and are
just affectionate right Robbie they're
just affection I got a scissor in the
line for a Magic Mountain who cares
that's right
let me enjoy the journey right it's not
always about the Final Destination
that's right it's about the journey and
the line if they put movies in the line
or something we could talk but they're
giving us nothing it does make it it
does make everything go faster were they
in the fast pass that's it that's what
we asked uh
but we're not doing anything wrong
that's what they said uh
police Lieutenant Scott Dahlgren said
that the man and the woman are both how
old we're gonna get a picture of these
guys and put them up
that's exactly why they called the cops
okay I thought you were gonna say that's
exactly why they call it the blues
[Laughter]
do you think this shirt says wrestling
yeah
looks like he's wrestling with his
facial hair I feel like Kyle can even be
critical of that beard you know I think
that looked you know less upset if they
were able to finish yeah exactly 100 she
looks perplexed they look interrupted is
what you're trying to say yeah they look
like they snuck into the amusement park
in the first place so like we may as
well go for HJ in line yeah by the way
how many times has that guy been
approached like hey man we need you over
operating the thing they think dude you
got to get over to the buccaneer
it's like Buccaneer what are you talking
about he loves Cobra Kai I mean they
should just be just be happy this guy's
going
guys
oh yeah they're both the same age they
are both the same age oh my that makes
it tough they are both okay so Eva how
old do you think these guys are
oh my God
see you in a minute
I listen the same age throws me off
because I would have said she's like 37
and he's like 26 yeah somehow
she's showing him a thing or two she
looks like the teacher that hooked up
with him in high school and then they're
getting that together 12 years later
like oh my God we can do this now we can
do this now it's okay you know what
you're right [__] it I'm gonna go with
28 then 28 28. Robbie what do you think
how old are they both I think I think
like siblings yeah yeah that's fair that
could be an intest element
s twins because they are the same age
a lot of people don't know but I just
saw a thing about incest it's apparently
one percent of you [__] oh my God all
right disgusting I see you okay I think
32. 34 was nice who was 34. someone
shouted 34. she got shut down that's my
[__] right there thank you well we let
him guess yeah that's right okay I'll do
32 and 34 for her does she get her say
yeah
Dan I can't understand it your mouth is
too wide while you're talking right now
trying to find a medium yeah just
kidding uh Kyle how old are they I think
when you do drugs with somebody you
start looking the same age
who's moving yeah yeah drugs really
throw an even Steven wrench into the
whole aging operation
what are you feeling Kyle I think she
started the drugs okay young dudes are
horny so he got into the drugs with her
29 29. all right you just like two
dollar one dollared me right there like
like Price is Right at me no no no no
price is right it's just close the
street closest to the pin okay sick
closest to them
I'm gonna I'm gonna go
39. yeah what there's not a gray on
either of them and they're not going to
like dark and lovely they're not
colorful well this is this to be fair
these photos were shot with a sidekick
so
why can't the police department get a
better [__] cat no no
either way they both of them don't have
the visitation right you say 39. so
Robbie says 32 someone shot at 34 out
there you say 29 Eva you said 28. okay
I'm gonna oh yeah I'm gonna say 36. 36
36. okay all right
Jason welcome to town what's your guess
26. I see a hand right here what's your
name Tim what's your guess welcome to
town
that's right
they're not in the year of our air Lord
yeah I see a big hand right there
what's your name
James welcome to town dude okay all
right 35 all right Jake okay all right
uh they are sometimes they see a UFO
yeah yeah right I'm sorry just this is a
point that bothers me about the camera
brought up
you set a point it's at a Tipping Point
Society if we could change it now
sometimes to give you a picture of UFO
it's so [__] grainy I believe this
[__] if it was just taken on a regular
iPhone that's right this is my whole
this is my whole life Robbie give me a
picture that makes sense right you can't
be bringing me a grainy you know [__]
Blackberry somebody's somebody's always
I said I know it's off topic a bit but
if anybody works in the tech I know
we're an SFO if anybody has if you're
taking the pictures here of the S I
can't wait to hear what Kyle is about to
say right now
all requests it's nothing but appreciate
every time bigfoot is spotted right some
deer hunter [__] fumbling peeling
open a Razer phone all right
like they're open like they're open in
an orange an orange yeah that's correct
to be like oh hold still and then get
dude you want that play it was your
complaint
years right your complaint has been
talked about in chat rooms and Bigfoot
societies three iPhones for the rural
community not only for access to
information yeah regarding agriculture
but also documenting these things that
we believe in but have no
also get rid of motion smoothing on all
televisions as a default it's turned off
nobody wants it I think you called the
program where you hand out the phones to
the country people picks for dicks there
you go
thank you
we're gonna move to amateur porn to
cover some costs anyway
all right point it to the skies when
you're not getting into each other we
will be right back on Aliens and other
assault Mysteries
I told you these two people these two
beautiful people
are 38 years old 38 years old Daniel
[Applause]
dance
they have found the Fountain of Youth it
is uh in line at a ride at Cedar Point
that's a young that's acting young
that's behaving Young
be young act the age you want to be have
you ever been to Kat Stella contestant
in New York yes so you know how they
have a sign like where Harry Met Sally
like they had like the the fake orgasm
thing which I could also do to a team
but anyway sure you could
um they should have it in this line at
the cedar pits this is where these two
38 year olds [__] yeah I would say where
Harry Met skanky
[Laughter]
yes I can't top that yes
uh the charge will be upgraded to a
misdemeanor one because the victims that
witnessed it were under the age of 18.
oh my God uh it did occur over near the
freak Show which is part of Cedar
Point's hallow weekends so that seems
appropriate
time yeah the couple is due in court
soon to face charges Sandusky Police say
about six weeks ago they arrested
another couple for allegedly having sex
on the Giant Wheel ride at Cedar Point
oh that's what's amazing Ferris wheel I
don't want to just do that maybe this is
the new action park uh sure this guy hit
this guy clearly is wearing jankos
nobody saw that thing this guy was
wearing Juggalo pants nobody knew dude
he was a couple of clasps and things
going on one more guess in this story
all right this incident took place
around what time on August 14th on the
ride this is the sex in the ferris wheel
ride 11 A.M 11 A.M wow I'm gonna go
because it's Halloween I bet this is
like a horror nights uh type deal I'm
gonna say 9 p.m 9 p.m oh this what what
was the date what it's this was on
August 14th I thought you said it was a
holiday
well this is another sex at Cedar Park
you can't change
another one I'm guessing sex in the
ferris wheel
but you know the
we're only finding out about this
because it's like Ohio white trash [__]
right people are jerking each other off
at Disneyland all the time all the time
and they're keeping it under wraps to
see their image pure yeah let's not
judge these people so much exactly let's
look inward California
that's right it's like hj's going down
and Knott's Berry Farm every day that's
the show
is there a better term for edging than
Knott's Berry like yeah
you don't think
Walt Disney was diddling these [__]
kids on the Dumbo ride wake up all right
I don't know about that okay but I do
think there are people who walk around
Disneyland like hey where do you get
those lightsabers that is not a
lightsaber oh Jesus
for this for when they were doing stuff
yeah I'll go 2 p.m 2 p.m 2 37 p.m
[__] 238.
nice I like your style I like it ring
the bell
I'm gonna say uh 6 p.m okay it's the 3
A.M of Day drink it is it's [__] time
that's right all right should I just
give the answer because we've been on
this story for a long time uh it
happened on the ferris wheel at 7 15 p.m
oh yeah
those kids should have been home for
dinner this couple should be exonerated
exactly it's after dark 7 15 p.m all
right and that is our first story books
[Applause]
Eva Kim we're in break why don't you
take us to a break
welcome back to the show you guys we are
back yeah here we go way to go ran thank
you very much should we find out what
people are doing Kyle how can people see
you where can they find you when you're
doing your live [__] what you're moving
into that right yeah sure plugs plugs I
just got sexed yes yeah you got sexed up
buy whatever you did thank you you can't
stand you're Fanning yourself off
telling me to plug my Instagram handle
that's right
explain what you just did to all of us
does anybody else need a beer by the way
like do I could go get some more beers
yes I it got wet in here yes it did
my phone's wet I can't find my handles
right now
Sports circuited all right Robbie how
can people find you calcanein [__]
Robbie's at kylekonane.com or whatever
yeah that's my name and if you put it on
the internet you'll find you there
you can plug much like socials and you
can plug something else folks
it just got large down here but speaking
of uh for nudes you can hit up me on
Instagram and Robbie Hoffman a couple of
dicey photos up there a couple of nip
slips Robbie Hoffman r-o-b-y and on uh
Twitter at I am Robbie there you go I
love it I love that we're here
danabankirk.com for all his stuff and uh
lyric Hyperion theater Irene two and I
have a show there I love it let's do it
if you're in LA and uh we got a good job
thanks yeah you just I did the show
Robbie all right should I jump into
story two you guys yeah I think you
should
this story was sent in by a good friend
Jake groney at Jake broney now I don't
know if this was this is like a Fox 43
story so but it feels very New York
posty I'm sorry I need to interrupt
there are zero nip slips here can you
please point me to the direction you're
on my website
go to Instagram happy yeah
okay you ready for this oh Jesus
[Applause]
holy fans only fans
can watch that
Robbie my in-laws are in this room and
the in-laws are in the house
they already follow her on Instagram
okay
you guys ready here we go nothing but a
bad time which is part of a song that
you will scammer posing as a glam metal
metal singer bilks woman out of a lot of
money we will guess that I'm out later
police say scammer posing as a glam
metal rocker this camera you'll see 320.
isn't this how they took down Gary
Glitter am I wrong
he took himself down is what that
happened right there all right Lancaster
County Pennsylvania Northern of course
Northern Lancaster County Regional
Police say a Lancaster woman lost more
than and it is a lot of money in an
online scam when the subject was posing
as the lead singer from a prominent glam
metal band
I don't know what glam metal is like I
know what metal it is poison a hair band
is [__] deserves to lose everything
she ever has what are we doing thought
we were about to be best friends
backstage and now you've just uh you
hurt like ladies stop giving your money
it goes the other way the men give you
money thank you
[Applause]
so on board with that wait wait hold on
we're on top once and now they're at the
bottom that's right the victim a Penn
Township resident told police that she
believes she was in direct contact with
the singer and transferred the money
using a cash exchange app
you know how the lead singer of bands
say hey can you just get up on that cash
exchange app and send [__] my way the
nlcrpd which to me sounds like what
happens to you when you smoke too much
in Canada yeah yeah she's suffering from
nlcrpd reminds citizens to make certain
that they are dealing with who they're
dealing with when making an electronic
transition I would say even if Brett
Michaels said send me some money don't
[__] do it don't do it what is name
can we name one prominent glam metal
band yet Eva [__] Cinderella poison
Motley Crue Bingo
Bang Bang Tango
Mr Mister
they obviously this is their Kink this
is their fetish to give away their money
to a man who's bruising them Slaughter
um some of these are just metal and the
only prominent one you've said is I
would still say kiss kiss prominent is a
subjective term yes like what's
prominent in your house unless in the
Hair Nation and SiriusXM daily these are
all prominent in my drive time commute
so you gotta make sure who you're
dealing with prominent feels like the
wrong term to describe like a glam rock
band like prestigious maybe that feels
more right distinguished sounds like a
glam rock band yeah we were at The
prominent concert last night
oh ask yourself what you're all
listening to on a regular basis just a
whole lot of striper and Vixen all right
I don't like Eminem and Linkin Park
yeah so be ashamed of yourself for your
own things
can I tell you that my 15 year old
daughter played me Limp Biscuit the
other day like I'd never heard it and
she's got great taste in music and I was
like this [__] cuts through yes
and I looked her dead in the eye and I
said give me something to break here he
goes
[Applause]
again sorry
no you get no Bell for that I know I get
nothing
while the police department didn't
identify which singer this scammer was
impersonating to me that's all I'd want
to know period danger danger Bullet Boys
glam
the final bit of advice in the press
release offered a tantalizing hint
Hanoi Rocks are you doing kicks
so they won't tell you who it is it's
Jaden Smith no no
you ready room this is what the police
said in their press release remember
guys every rose has its thorn
poison being originally from Western
Pennsylvania that's it when attempting
these high-risk money transfers the
press release continued by the way
totally plausible Vince Neil could have
like I think Vince Neil didn't he do
skating with the Stars he did everything
okay Ben still is not gravitational
incapable of skating with anybody all
right
so let's so let's get down to it right
now how much money did this person who
was impersonating Vince Neil Bilk them
out of this woman out of it how much it
was Vince Neil it wasn't I don't think
it was Vince Neil it was Vince Neil
Western Pennsylvania well that's Motley
Crue oh yeah so it was Brad poison was
based poison started in Western
Union was it Vince Neil impersonating
that's Michael's for the money
yes
it was Michael's he had that show on VH1
I'm gonna have sex on this bus with all
these girls right marry his daughter
by her
it's one percent of everybody is doing
incest wake up
one percent
no and it's the and that's the one
percent Bernie Sanders was warning us
that's right the one percent of the one
percent of the one percent now because
they keep the money in the family
yeah you know I'm gonna say eleven
thousand dollars and then I'm gonna go
get me and Robbie a beer thank you I'm
gonna say six thousand dollars eleven
thousand six thousand what do you say
okay she's in Western Pennsylvania she
does not have six thousand dollars
how much 800 bucks
and it was all and that's all most of it
was scratch-offs that's right nothing
wrong with that and gift certificates to
Hershey Park that's right and a Terrible
Towel the gift certificates meaning
handwritten no lhj in line for the
coaster that's all right I don't know
that that the stuff that goes on in line
at Hershey Park is a different story all
together I'm going up I'm gonna go 22
000.
I'll take three guests let me do one let
me do one I'm gonna guess mine I'm gonna
say
ooh seventy nine thousand dollars wow
wow 79
000. what's your name hi Jenna welcome
to town what's your guess
42. I haven't just done it before I
could tell any rise how much you lose 42
000. 34. 34 000. no it didn't happen no
it happened go ahead yes what's your
name
hi Catherine welcome to town
yes
whatever a baggy costs in West
Pennsylvania
17.
all right you guys ready some boot
Sudafed costs over in Lancaster
so you ready for this uh she was built
out of ten thousand dollars
nice work tell me nothing but a good
time is what they tried to do at the
beginning of that honestly
not not too much to learn that lesson
yeah
she's gonna do you think she'll do it
again yeah they're addicted it's a
fact first concert ever went to poison
and warrant Rosemont Horizon Rosemont
baby Rosemont Horizon 1991. my first
concert was also Rosemont Horizon what
would you see Amy Grant oh oh you grew
up with Jesus
[__] yeah dude I'm rock with JC Jesus
brought you to the Horizon for some Amy
Graham baby baby
[Music]
turn this [__] song off now
stop foreign
[Music]
we're not going to all right that is uh
Story number two Dance Story number two
Dan can you can you give These Fine
people just a taste of what we're an
annual tradition when we come back we
will run down the things that we stuck
inside of ourselves let's go on a 22.
it's a tradition it's a tale as old as
time it is uh it's like the masters of
sticking [__] in your body exactly all
right uh Eva take us to break shall we
or into the break who's next
Hang on we're not going to talk about
the sticking of the stuff oh no that's
coming up after the break oh excellent
that was a teaser okay great so so Jason
Europe oh yeah I'm not gonna sing a
whole song I want yeah you don't have to
sing anything but I know you probably
will give it to me so listen the first
time that I really met Jason was on a
magical karaoke kind of like an art car
but it's like never been a burning man
um in Los Angeles called the rvip lounge
this was actually I you know what I
believe it might have been your
birthdays it might have been the first
time we've we had a birthday party for
you guys with the rvip lounge just like
a tiny it's like a it's like a bus
basically like a tour bus that's been
gutted and retrofitted and turned into a
karaoke Lounge it's really fun it's a
good time it's a beautiful thing it will
change your life anyway
um this was a kind of a shocker uh and I
really felt like I knew after this so
this is Jason's
you can sing on any bus
yeah you feeling this
one two three go let's go get up get up
get up go I won't I won't I can't Jay
come on
put that Raspberry Beret on I wish I had
a Raspberry Beret
this is so 90s it's just so 90s I love
how long this intro is I know
part-time in a five and dime well boss
was Willie McGee Willie St Louis
baseball Cardinal
time that it didn't like my kind cause I
was a bit too leisurely tell them
that I was busy doing something close to
nothing but different than the day
before okay that's when I saw
I saw she walked in through the out so
she's a little slow
so he sees her it's like can't you find
in a second hand still doesn't know
which door to go in or out of she pushes
the pole
am I smart
Raspberry Beret
I think I love her mostly because she
doesn't know which door to go in and out
of oh that's well done there we go thank
you
[Applause]
a fun one thank you
go home their roommate's gonna go what
kind of show did you see and they're
gonna go I don't know
I'm not really it's kind of like a
variety show I think the Jewish lesbian
yelled at us for a while told us that
one percent of us were gonna have sex
with our relatives
I read it in the Atlantic what do you
want from it what do you want from me
do you know that one percent of every
story in the Atlantic is true
guys set between us no one percent of
all Americans have completed an article
in the Atlantic they're 49
000 pages long
I have the subscription I gotta get my
money's worth that's right I agree sixty
dollars a year now oh my God Jesus
by the way hey less for the New York
Times you see her started out no not
doing the time they got me good on the
crossword they're out
open your mouth wide and read this story
uh so a few years ago someone sent us a
story that is a collection of medical
reports about things that Americans got
stuck inside themselves I think we did
it for the first time here then we did
it every year after where we got the
chance yeah the brief Hiatus uh the past
couple years but now we're back yeah at
sketchfest ready this was uh this was
not sent in by anyone this year although
russet Burbank at russet underscore
Burbank I said I just want to request
when you do the annual what did we get
stuck up ourselves story for dumb people
town you give credit to at de facto
media that is who puts it together I'm
gonna go one step further and give
credit to Barry petchesky at Barry they
got in early
yeah that guy's a killer who's following
any of these handles oh I don't know
okay we go if you bet this is what the
article reads before we get into the
list
if you've ever put anything inside
yourself and gotten it out again without
needing medical attention
congratulations right here
[Applause]
there you go things went way better for
you than they did so many other poor
souls yeah this is a tribute to American
Ingenuity American perseverance and
above all else American recklessness
stick up with him
all reports are taken from U.S consumer
product safety commissions database of
emergency room visits all descriptions
are verbatim
and as always remember that a flared
bass is your best friend that's it the
other notice that we will give all of
these are uh notated because they are
not in criminal relations so
he'd safely assume he's hearing that
this was all consensual people wanted
this to happen
and we start objects are sorted by
orifice working South yeah we start up
here start with the ears
for fun I'll do it by myself if you guys
don't want to join me so there's quite a
times where people say that they quote
unquote fell yeah and as I was reading
this every time to myself I just found
myself going whoa so I'm gonna do that
whenever somebody Falls here we go ready
here we will not have picks for all
these because I want to get to it yeah
I'm gonna just read them in order as
they were literally entered in verbatim
into this database first one here we go
here
Bibi shot from a distance whoa that's
that's [__] cool that is
somebody from across the backyard you
get it right in their ear you win
entered is such a polite turn yeah did
they die no they're like do they have
hearing they lost it he just got the BB
out yeah it's a BB from a BB gun oh yeah
oh yes so isn't it going really fast
slingshot or just a hard toss yeah it's
very in power
you know from far away kind of like you
know it'll I don't know anything that's
supposed to think about guns it slows
down right yeah that's how many times
you pump it yeah uh that's from uh okay
that's from my story about the amusement
park you ever see that movie where the
kid gets the BB gun
I always wanted that BB gun Oh you mean
A Christmas Story A Christmas Story that
must have been so much fun to watch at
your house as a kid at Christmas that
you asked if anybody's ever seen A
Christmas Story yeah well I saw it
recently it looked like a good gun I
would get that one you know I wish
they'd play that once on TBS on
Christmas it's hard to find you gotta
find the laser disc in a vintage store
ready to watch that next quote is what I
was written quote was seen for earache
but found to be positive for cocaine
metabolites oh
next up set
wait
insects yeah I know you heard it he said
insects account for one percent of all
the things in your ears we're gonna skip
haven't you heard
of that is he's got a crazy Coke here
don't you threaten me with a good time
no it's like when you do cocaine in your
ear you hear really good pictures you
think this music sounds good now dab a
little in your airpods yes no plug it in
it [__] wins
this is a marathon not a Sprint all
right I know I'm sorry
if you want I just never been in a
podcast where somebody rules you know
the scars I like what Kyle was saying
okay ready thank you charger computer
stylus what
wait this is still of the Year this is
still in the air there's all different
people's ears a charger yes what kind of
a charger it was here it was Philip
Rivers
um
sports fans
oh a charger plug yeah
I've got my car keys pretty far in my
ear did you and if I didn't have my car
keys in my ear itched I could see a
charger doing the thing yeah I was
thinking like you know like a power tool
I'm a lesbian forgive me yeah you know
the charger pack yeah yeah so I'm
thinking how do you get that in no
that's
that's because I keep mine on Ice you're
so much of a lesbian you never plugged
your phone in you went straight to Ryobi
yeah went straight to Ryobi
yeah I did that's what I want I want
that charger I have no need for
communication yeah I have a drill that
needs to be powered up I need to build a
deck I don't want to talk to anybody I
have to build that every woman I just
met I am currently building a deck the
Milwaukee family of uh rechargeable
power tools that's right
I just talked to to your wife about the
deck with a hot tub shout out danger
design thank you Amy hey
it will interior designer extraordinaire
she's helping me with one of those
Barrel hot tubs you know with the wood
all around yeah
I don't know if she's gonna help you
with it but yeah
absolutely but yes I promise
why is he faster Pussycats
um all right sorry do you know the
cufflink tried using a knife to cut it
out but was unsuccessful oh my God I dig
it why did you get a cufflink
so let's cut it out with a knife cut
around the cufflink through your ear
that's not because the sharp you think
you can get the point in there and like
fling it wet tissues in both ears yeah
yeah that's fine we have a picture of
this next one because I didn't know what
I don't want to look monkey noodle
what's that I don't know if we have that
pick feel free monkey noodle sounds like
a pet picture number one there we go
that's what a monkey noodle is I've I
had no idea but they had one stuck in
there like it if you told me like monkey
noodle is what JLo calls Ben Affleck I
would believe you hang on
hangout product do we know what does do
we know what this is we're just wait in
line for Space Mountain so I figured I'd
give him the old monkey noodle for a
little while you know all of a sudden
we're getting written up by the cops
it's a San Francisco company right there
you know what I got I got all the money
in the world I like to buy my monkey
noodles individually all right I don't
eat none of this [__] value pack [__]
all right let's go you're gonna call
something new and all the things you can
do you can't eat it you can stretch it
pull it twirl it all right
okay whatever I guess my riff can go
suck a dick
we aren't too that whole yet
that's another hole we'll get there yeah
yeah
same
thing don't jump ahead
here labia we're gonna get there all
right again it's the clitoris it's
enlarged the labia is fine fine two
earbuds in the same ear canal
where did I why is this music coming
inside let's keep going
what plastic sword who did that
thermometer quote mistakenly use shoe
glue instead of ear drops oh
lighter fluid air freshener bead p piece
of ice cream cone what push pin quote
doing magic trick at school put a pencil
eraser in ear and was unable to retrieve
it
glow stick Battleship game piece oh
candle wax rock well cause why are they
keep lying that like you can't put a
Q-tip in your ear it's like that's what
feels good we're doing it so make it
safe folks right I agree we're all doing
it make it safe final one on here quote
fruit fly was on her headphone which she
put her in her ear and felt buzzing used
hydrogen peroxide to kill the fly but
with persistent burning discomfort and
ear unsure if the fly is still alive oh
my God
we now go to nose by the way this could
be like a Marvel origin story that's
right she's fruit fly yeah yeah all
right ready for nose I'm on board with
all the ear things that's right gum
wrapper okay used match used to match
yarn yarn yarn
candy heart yeah Tic Tacs sure quote
says he was smelling a magnet and it
went up a
oh don't you know what sometimes you
gotta stop and smell the magnets
rice rice do you think the magnet and
when it went up he's like he thought
there was metal in his head that was
attracted to it I didn't do this the
magnet he's like I knew I got metal in
my brain
and he's so metal dude right I'm I'm
every person you're listening but
haven't reported it yet
I'll smell some I'll smell the [__] out
of some magnets man rice vitamin D yeah
put a jewel up his nose while making a
crown
Oh I thought he meant like a jewel so
did I exactly popcorn kernel sure making
a crown
what are you doing today well I'm gonna
smell some so many more backstories here
than the hand job at the amusement park
now who's independently making crowns
like somebody's gonna need this yeah I
gotta
hj's everybody yeah Colonel gummy worm
quote put an LED light in her right
nostril in an attempt to prank her
brother but was that unable to get it
out oh yes this will show him yeah
flower
orange peel and now we have our second
pick of the night
fishing lure what no
she got hooked up
the nose up the nose Kyle that leg came
back that was so hard there we go go the
wrong way there we go fish give away my
bits fishing lure okay ready let's keep
going go back to the logo go back to the
penis hole
yet glue piece of computer mouse this is
in the nose diesel fuel oh Jesus
geez I like the smell when you're
filling up your car I do like that smell
it's cold
it's a real thing and then final for the
nose quote a book or a bug
a book or a bug they don't know a book
or a bug up their nose what was it
Catcher in the Rye no no it was a beetle
I'm sorry
I'm always confused you ready for the
throat
whoa
slow down when you're eating people
swallow swords for entertainment that's
right
okay ready
sword cane small flashlight a SIM card
glue stick quote Thumbtack was holding
curtains up at a window patient inhaled
deeply near the attack and then coughed
and swallowed Thumbtack confirmed on
x-ray oh God
in front of everything you just listed
it's every SoundCloud rapper that's
popular right now little small
flashlight little SIM card little glue
stick little SIM cards huge right now
little SIM card little glue stick I mean
sure they are thank you for having the
courage to say that I'll swallow the
same card right now I had a headache and
some Dyke told me to take a peppermint
tablet and I was gagging on that for how
I can't get it down if it was the size
of a SIM Card
Bingo chip
dog toy cat toy expensive coin from coin
collection
you I know
safe keeping yeah insulin needle
that's not where it goes golf pencils
stack of Staples
magic wands
three three cigarettes oh
I've been there that's a dare right yeah
yeah I bet you can't do another one is
what his brother said
watch me this one might be one of the
dumbest ones I've ever read right after
right after three cigarettes
I don't think it's possible
but to take foil
foil foil wrapped burrito oh
listen I understand you ever get a
little paper and a bite yeah yes no okay
calm down they have that felt foil
that's half paper half foil listen have
I digested a piece or two in my life
sure sure they'd ever bitten
but they didn't say they like just
straight up like oh Magic burrito yeah
they and then just started eating a
chrome burrito
honey oh we've all eaten some tin foil
right yes but we got it down huh yeah
honey where's my space burrito I ate it
but if you're out having a night and
then you're hungry and you get a Big
Burrito you're excited about yeah you
might eat some foil
is involved or something like that yeah
whatever yeah blackout like Edibles like
blackouts oh yeah
and here's the thing they know we're
eating the foil so make it food safe
there you go
take that take that Reynolds Wrap yeah
all right Moving On The Fat Cats down at
Reynolds Wrap when they hear this
podcast they're gonna be shaking in
their shoes
don't even get me started
Saran Wrap we cruised over stack of
Staples to pause on some foil a thing
that food's already wrapped in a stack
of Staples have never come anywhere near
food yeah literally you forgot to take
the foil off we all forget that foil is
on food a whole rack of Staples is
nowhere near food ever and we cruised
through that to get to this you can hit
a stoplight whenever your priorities are
incorrect on this podcast oh I've said
that for years hey honey
honey I my my burrito keeps falling
apart can you just staple it for me
together
thank you tea bag hair clip candy ring
with plastic tea bag is easy yeah you're
drinking the tea forget it it's gone
thank you I love to go put tea you ready
for the next pick quote dropped his
Otter Pop onto the floor which was
covered in metal shavings from a drill
press and continued to eat the honor oh
God come on dude yeah that's yes
it is what it is you're stopping on
things that make sense
you're skipping over stuff that makes no
sense for it to be even close to your
face let alone your mouth right you yell
when you want one stop down all of these
except the ones you're stopping so you
stuck in a person's mouth video game
control stop there stop there
oh no I understand that because remember
you had to blow in them that's the game
not the controller okay okay up down
left right b a swallow which one
Nintendo switch those are little a child
can consume that are these children
why are we shouting
because this list is incredulous
laser pointer yogurt foil crab shell
dried ornamental glass
people eat glass My Strange Addiction on
TLC people are eating these things don't
go to My Strange Addiction to legitimize
any of this
it's called My Strange Addiction those
people are [__] freaks oh listen I
know we're not supposed to Kink shame
but yeah
I ate glass King Shame you've been King
Shane That's My TLC show
by the way I would walk you've
embarrassed your family you eat glass
fix yourself I was all [__] up
that's you're like a [__] up Dr Phil
you know what I mean I thought
I like to eat Muffler Parts you [__]
up fix yourself
you deserve to be king shamed sometimes
you deserve it Kink shamed on TLC I'm so
watched [__] Dart darts on your list
a whole Dart yes that we should stop on
a dark we're literally stopping us a
full Dart but a dart I understand as
well because if you're standing by the
dark thing oh my God and it goes do you
swallow dude if you're a boy Dart hit my
mouth I'm so worried about the
repercussions of a dart hitting my mouth
I nervously swallowed a cop show that is
YouTube explaining a crime scene
Robbie is so like forgiving of every
single person that swallowed something
because you have to put
start next up oh wait I have one request
for an episode I have one request for an
episode the [__] who give away all
their money is a kink [__] shame them
give away your money it's your money you
give it away you never swallowed a dart
oh this guy pretended to be uh the guy
that died in uh the the important
but I gave him ten thousand dollars
did you eat and chew a glass Christmas
ornament no that's what you're gonna go
to jail for gingerbread man shaped
brooch yeah it's shaped like food
already okay good well threw three coins
up into the air and caught them in the
mouth and then swallowed them okay
yep fine that's what they did in the old
timing yeah
you'll never get my secrets small
small key to a diary is my favorite
Morrissey song is what I think
a book Dan guy guy who swallowed money
is Never Gonna Change
[Laughter]
fortune cookie
cookie there he goes I just got it she
just swapped it took me a minute take
out that twin thing I got it ready to go
to the pink yes
this is San Francisco it was made for
the penis
here we go I just want to say Robbie
said finally so the Kyle yeah still
jerking my mic stop
now
car key yeah wooden spoon oh car key was
just trying to turn himself off you're
talking I'm assuming these are all
self-imposed yes and as a dude with a
penis yes to the whole list okay I
haven't done it but you're the guy going
let's see what happens yeah if you are
the girlfriend or boyfriend or husband
or wife of the guy who stuck his thing
in then that can be a wonderful joke
between you is if you say to your wife
your wife or your partner honey can you
please bleep bleep my penis yeah that's
good where are my keys why don't you
check your penis Dave that's right
have you looked there because that's the
last time I saw it
okay
impression the penis hole is extra
small and I could be wrong
you can really get in there the penis
the penis hole is like what we're doing
to this list you can really stretch you
can stretch it out long
yeah no nailed it nailed it
pencil sure quote some beads zombies
some beads seven inch silicone tube sure
paper clip
just wants to stay organized
you got to keep your [__] together up in
there comb teeth comb teeth you're not
giving me any shapes that wouldn't fit
you know like avocado you know like
you're not
baseball glove exactly nice avocado is
like when a like when a boa constrictor
eats like a moose you know you're like
how is that I don't even understand how
that got in there and what could
possibly be in there
of soap quote
ceiling fan chain in his penis hole
States it has been in there since his
shower at 9 00 PM last night okay next
pick next pick oh my God that's that's
what it is but that makes sense it does
it does the light always hits me like I
should be shamed for this person's just
in your head Jay that that ceiling fan
chain
I never done that
screwdriver tip oh Phillips wow
I love that that was the question for
you inflatable sex toy okay deflated
deflated yeah you
you were sure
well is it our final one for penis cell
phone charger and I'm gonna ask you guys
real quick we're just gonna run it down
how many inches of the cord did he get
inside how many inches
okay 38 inches that's insane Randy seven
inches I love it seven inches two
two okay you're gonna say Android or
Apple
how many inches did it get in there six
six I said seven four
charger
14 inch wow he's coiling at some point
he's coils so here's the whole thing
of course you're playing with it yeah I
could say no no don't not of course not
of course not of course people are
playing with any [__] hole there is
I'm 46 have not played with it to get 14
inches of an Apple or Android product
but something in your
phone no no
no
yeah you know you have and what was it I
shockingly know no it's called sounding
so some people are into it you just have
to be yeah exactly who here be brave oh
God my man my man no he did not I I have
that avocado in my desk right now
no
we are now moving on to vagina okay
here we go ready we've only got nine
more orifices guys seriously we're gonna
be done by next summer
screw quote was holding a pen near her
vagina when the cap dislodged and stuck
inside you know you know how like you
like to write while you're naked sure
two pencil sharpeners sure
butterfly charm the 90s Are Back exactly
we have a pick for the next one because
this is all they said drinking cup oh oh
my God that makes so much sense that's
what comes up when you Google drinking
cups bobby pin sure golf ball right four
flashlight when I was first learning to
masturbate I wasn't sure what was doing
in the hole Yeah okay and pedophiles
hold your breath okay sure but I took a
pencil to try and do it and it was too
tight for the pencil but I was trying
with the pencil so I understand
you can erase the shame afterwards
there we go also works with a paper made
pen
uction at home but had no intention of
it becoming stuck no one on this list
well it's like that maybe your eyeballs
light up if you get it drumstick nail
polish bottle camera lens cap that's too
close unscented soap bar perfume soap
bar soap dispenser oh wow I had an ex
who liked to put things up a vagina and
tell me about it at the barge but you
know what I want to put up in my vagina
in my ear and you know we're really dirt
man what what did she say what she wrote
she would say like all kinds she would
go to her parents at some type of nice
house by the lake and she would put
garden tools and all kinds of her vagina
yeah she'd get really wet telling me
this stuff
vagina and that is spatula okay there
you go come on you gotta flip them eggs
that's right you gotta make some paint
oh
you gotta stay
no that's so much that's the best I got
give him a standing o variation come on
let's leave
all right
fish yep the next thing real fish I'm
sure what I imagine this is the picture
here we go small bird toy
that's 100 when it comes up what I
thought it was
I was wondering why we'd see him again
spread eagle
it's right there anybody could make
these jokes this isn't a piece silver
magnet sent in by wife he's trying to
match the one that won the nose that's
right he's trying to connect the two
quote sent in by wife for possible 16
ounce glass bottle in rectum possible
possible I love that there could be a
question that it wasn't out there it
might have been possibly scented yeah
it's right it's like a crawl space who
knows what we stashed inside no it's
like it's like your storage locker
piece of lamp piece of lamp there's a
quote handmade toy made out of metal
There You Go cube shaped toy crayon
ratchet wrench cube-shaped toy I solved
it there you go ratchet wrench T handle
wrench I watch a lot of prison shows and
I'll tell you I am not surprised at
anything that's right it all makes sense
you got to do something to forget the
time
he says was in shower and fell and the
shower stopper stuck up rectum wow yeah
you got to be careful Action Figure Head
action figure you wanted to get them
back together by the way who has a
shower stopper here's one I don't like
toilet brush a shower starter
patient complaining of rectal pain
patient admits to inserting sex toys how
many months prior Jason
four months four months Kyle
two two Robbie I was I would say too
okay two I would say five months five
I'll say three ten ten months
to admit inserting sex toys six months
prior hey spoon quote vibrator egg
patient not sure if passed in stool
there you go okay [__] have you ever
had a tampon any and you pull a tampon
out and another one comes out be brave
be brave
it's like the miracle of Hanukkah we
only thought one tampon was gonna come
out but there was enough for two really
it's very scary and and you're at risk
for TS there was enough tampons for
eight periods for all of the Maccabees
there was enough tampons for all of the
macanese
she has she has
dude that's what happened to the Chinese
balloon up in the [__] that is
fist-sized water balloons I guess I bet
it was sure it was a fist do we have a
picture for the next one
what oh my God don't do that don't do
that crochet needle sure fishing pole
well fishing lure was in which part of
the body it was in the nose nose nose so
maybe they were doing like a oroboros
kind of thing quote
by the way this room right now is a mess
it's like I I thank you I'm feeling the
emotions of the audience you guys are
all gonna get three sociology credits
for today
at University of San Francisco that's
right quote patient
s reusable ice pack there you go it is
reusable it's now Icy Hot not the term
that you use glass beer bottle sure had
a few beer years and then placed a long
wax candle into his rectum lost balance
and fell onto the couch and lost the
candle whoa
pill container cologne bottle perfume
bottle you just don't have to gender
assign our bottles you know what sex
toys are expensive and some of these
four [__] you guys are using whatever
they got they got a Yankee Candle jar
and a good time
quote says girlfriend put vibrator in
rectum while he was asleep that's all it
says yeah
sure that's what happened you got to
keep keep things special April fools
you'll respect this one will your ball
Bill your ball really eight ball eight
ball backpack
there you go there you go ran ran the
home stretch now boys yeah
quote patient says he was playing with a
container of athlete's foot spray and
accidentally it ended up in his rectums
that feels like a fall right that is
some tough acting connected my friend
plastic candy holder I don't even know
what that is that's Pez it's Pez
uh piece of broom handle sure you don't
want all of it no no
quote put in butt plug then fell asleep
now can't find butt plugs
don't you fall asleep and forget where
you put things
stainless Steel Rod oh it's safe that
could be what it's for that's just
medical ice cream cone sure just
just eat it break it down that's right
some of these waffle cones are you
talking like sugar cones yeah that's
what I'm saying
down some of these scores are getting
thick Monopoly piece and you know it's
the Hat you know
you're saying he's an asshat
it could be all the hotels
what are you googling to get all this if
The Defector does that okay Dan take us
home final one
two two Booker chips because of a bet
there you go yeah that's it friends time
to cash out
all right you guys that was a show yeah
thank you hey Ryan go get our thing go
get our thing we're gonna be right over
here uh first of all I want to thank
Robbie Hoffman everybody for coming here
Robbie and opening up her life
Kyle Kinane everybody
[Applause]
Daniel Van Kirk
we're gonna be over there we will be
signing these awesome posters if you
want one that Jeff Tice made uh it's
getting shirts we're dead set on hanging
with you guys we are and Eva cam watch
you play the last song Oh the last one
is Dan's song
the night that I really met Dan I will
not we get to walk out on Daniel Van
Kirk the night that I truly met you was
in a karaoke bar at two in the [__]
morning in New York yes
yes and you came out like out of the
dead of night and it literally had a
prop in your pocket and sunglasses and
you brought the most beautiful rendition
of this [__] I have ever heard so let's
friends thank you on the way out you
guys
Dan I wish you had the harmonica in your
pocket oh God He Wore a younger man's
clothes once I will not
but we love you guys sing a little bit
Dan we'll be over there thank you guys
so much we love you guys
guys we gotta get back to work
[Applause]